I think Craig was lonely that's what I
think really got him more than anything
is Tina Turner is opening up about her
son's death the 79 year old singer sat
down with Gayle King for an interview on
CBS Sunday morning and got candid about
her son Craig Raymond Turner's death at
the age of 59 last July
following his passing a spokesperson for
the Los Angeles County coroner's office
told ET quote the call was reported as a
suicide gunshot wound I have pictures
all around of him smiling and I I think
I'm sensing that he's in a good place
I really did Tina also opened up about
her tumultuous relationship with Ike
Turner the two were married from 1962 to
1978 when I asked me to marry him I knew
it was for a reason but I had to say yes
I knew our it was gonna be a fight and
so then when we drove to marry that
wasn't my idea of my wedding and while
Tina shared Craig with ex Raymond Hill I
adopted Craig after he and Tina tied the
knot he was so cruel he was cruel
because he depended on me he didn't like
that he had had to depend on me and I
didn't want to start a fight because as
always a black eye
broken nose a busted lip a rib tina who
was born Anna Mae Bullock said that Ike
was quote very good to her in the
beginning but it all changed when a song
they recorded together got the attention
of a record exact it just came home from
the record company who said he was the
record I said who's Tina you're Tina and
I said Tina Tina Turner I was really
hard to say in the beginning now Tina
says she's a happy person
thanks in large part to her husband
Erwin Bach whom she married in 2013 it
was the first time that I got married as
far as I was concerned I have everything
when I sit at the Lake Zurich in the
house
I am so serene no problems I had a very
hard life that I didn't put blame on any
thing or anyone I got through it
I lived through it with no blame